and now have you guys obviously you're a
fan of the One Direction I can see but
as one direction met in McCallum New
Zealand hell what one direction before I
thought you'd have a big a beard and we
didn't you come close to meeting in New
Zealand we did yeah we were on tour in
of Zealand and they were filming yes and
you were meant to come and see us
filming yeah the day after your final
concert so I thought I'd go and have a
look at them see who they are
very enjoyable thank you thank you it
was a very she no wizards I think he
wins a small show I mean it was just you
know no fireworks or anything but and a
quite a small theater to remember oh
in the day anyway they didn't turn
up the next day to visit us because why
I don't know why what had happened in
your last night I think we know I know I
mean maybe we'll say yeah your plane
might have been moved early or something
now in mechanics I saw the pictures of
you all at the premiere on Monday night
oh yeah
and I mean it's been part of your life
for nigh on 14 years now so it must was
that an emotional night or whether the
emotions happened already
yeah well it's over you know we're not
we've not been working on The Hobbit for
some time now but it was very moving I
mean you go and these kids have been
sleeping out all night when you know
about this but the fear these people
were not born when we started making
Lord of the Rings No so it's a big part
of their lives and that's that's very
sweet isn't it and the BBC or all six
movies now and show them to their kids
not that that's what's nice we've made
classics
that's lovely and also it will take
nearly a day to watch it be done have
you done it yeah I think I did I was off
school L once I think I did I'm with my
friend Evan or so but although we might
avoid one or two three or third of them
you're amazing right out so are you
just so moved all the cheap was this I
want to strain your eyes out on your
penis with the word el dente on it